اتسعت دائره عصيان الاوامر العسكريه داخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي رفضا لاصرار نتنياهو على
تمرير التعديل القضائي وقانون الكنيست
وتتزامن هذه الضغوط الداخليه بوجهيها
المدني والعسكري مع اخرى خارجيه قادت على
وقع مظاهرات معارضه لزياره رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الى لندن لالغاء البيان
المشترك لرئيسي وزراء البلدين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
دوافع ودلالات تصاعد ضغوط الداخليه
والخارجيه التي باتت تستهدف نتنياهو
وحكومته اليمينيه المتطرفه ومن رؤيه التي
تقود واشنطن في التعامل معها
الى اي مدى يمكن لنتنياهو ان يتحمل
وحكومته تلك الضغوط وما هي الخيارات
المتاحه بيد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي في
التعامل معها
والى اين قد تؤول تلك الضغوط الداخليه
التي وصلت حتى عصيان الاوامر العسكريه
وتلك الخارجيه خاصه اذا ما اصر نتنياهو
على تمرير التعديل القضائي وقانون الكنيست
واي انعكاس لكل ذلك على الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
متعدده الجبهات هي معارك رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامينه يهو هذه الايام وسبب
الاساسي اصراره على المضي قدما في اقرار
التعديل القضائي وقانون الكنيست عدا عن
التصعيد المستمر ضد الفلسطينيين على صعيد
الداخليه واضافه لمظاهر العصيان العسكري
تستمر المظاهرات ضد سياسه نتنياهو التي
يعتبرها المحتجون دفعا بدوله اسرائيل نحو
الديكتاتوريه
النائبه العامه في اسرائيل غالي باهراف
قالت ان تورط نتنياهو في مقترحات تتعلق
بالاصلاحات القضائيه غير قانوني محذره من
تداعيات قضائيه لكل ذلك
تطورات يتابعها المجتمع الدولي عن كذب
خاصه الولايات المتحده التي استدعت في
خطوه نادره السفير الاسرائيلي لدى واشنطن
مايك هرتزوك للاحتجاج على مضيع حكومه
نتنياهو في المشاريع الاستيطانيه موقع
اكسيوس نقل عن مسؤولين في اداره بايدن
قوله ان المسؤولين الامريكيين كانوا
يدركون انها ستحدث ازمه مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه عند نقطه ما لكنهم حاولوا
تاجيلها قدر الامكان
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع البدايه من تل ابيب
مع جولان برهوم الباحث والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
يعني السؤال ازاءه كل هذه التطورات
الحاصله في اسرائيل ما هو الاثر المباشر
على نتنياهو وحكومته مساله العصيان
العسكري عصيان الاوامر العسكريه من جنود
الاحتياط
والطيارين احتجاجا على الاصلاح القضائي
وسياسات حكومه نتنياهو
بدايه مرحبا وتحياتي لك وللجميع اشكر لكم
على هذا الاستضافه الكريمه انظر من احد
البرلمان الاسرائيلي من ناحيه الارقام
بنيامين نتناول عنده اغلبيه واضحه ربما
غير ساحقه 64 مقعد ما هذا العصيان هذا
العصيه عصيان اسف ولكن ربما هذه فجوه من
فجوات داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وداخل
مؤيدين بنيامين نتنياهو يعني جزء من
اليمين الاسرائيلي غير موافق او يريد
تعديلات ولكن لا يريد اصلاح كامل صريع
السؤال المركزي سياسيا اولا يعني الاحتيان
وامر خطير في اعتقادي هناك اعتقادي اجماع
كامل في اسرائيل ان رفض اوامر عسكريه ولو
اذا هناك عدم موافقه مع حكومه منتخبه وامر
خطير انا افهم متعاطف مع جنود الاحتياط ان
نفسي كنت في الجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي ولكن
هذا اعتقادي لا يغير
الارقام المبنى البرلماني
السؤال السؤال هنا يعني
حتى الان لا نسال عن تعديل الارقام داخل
الكنيست السؤال انه هذا التطور يعتبر
يعتبر في المجتمع الاسرائيلي تطور خطير هل
هذا سيدفع نتنياهو الى التراجع خطوه الى
الوراء الى اعاده النظر بهذه القرارات
يعني هذا هو السؤال ام سيتحمل نتنياهو هذا
الضغط ويتجاهل هذا العصيان والمظاهرات
المليونيه الان اصبحت
انظر هنا اذا نتحدث على قله قليله قليلا
للغايه القليل الصغيره داخل جنود الاحتياط
الاسرائيليين ونحن نستطيع ان نقول لا نرى
مشكله في ذلك ولكن اذا نحن نتحدث كما انت
ذكرت على الظاهره مركز
داخل جيش الدفاع وعصيان ما كان خلال تاريخ
دوله اسرائيل ربما 82
ربما في الانتفاضه الاولى ربما
الثانيه ولكن نحن ما شاهدنا الظاهره
السؤال المركزي وانا اريد ان اكمل اجابتي
اذا يسمح لي
نحن نرى ان هذه الظاهره تكون عند جمهور
اليمين الاسرائيلي اذا نرى وانا الان لو
سمحت ارجع او ارجع الحديث الى برلمان
الاسرائيلي الى الكنيست
نرى هذا الاحتجاج المكثف الذي يؤثر على
اعزائي الكنيست من حزب الليكود يعني نرى
طوار داخل حزب داخل حركه الليكود فهبنا
ربما يغير
بالنقطه معينه حديث نتنياهو امسي
الحديث هنا الحديث عن انت انت مازلت تتحدث
هنا عن الداخل الاسرائيلي كما نفهم منك
انه لن يكون هناك تغيير في سياسات نتنياهو
رجاء وباختصار حتى الضغوط الخارجيه يعني
الضغوط الولايات المتحده ما حصل في لندن
اليوم كان لافتا جدا هذا الضغط حتى
الخارجي والدوله على نتنياهو ايضا لن يغير
في الامر شيئا باختصار
انا انا لا اتقرب استاذي الكريم من من اي
سؤال بدون شك بنيامين الطنياهو يتعرض الى
مشاكل او مشاكل وازمات اجنبيه هو واقف
امام هذه ولكن تاريخيا استاذي استاذي
الكريم دائما كانت ازمات او عدم موافقه او
خلافات بالنسبه لمناطق يهود والسامره
الضفه الغربيه بين
امريكيه على فكره من الحسبين وبين دوله
اسرائيل اي حكومه من حكومات اسرائيل يعني
اختلافات كانت دائما ولكن انا اريد ان
اتطلع على الامور بشكل ايجابي زيارات
مستمره في المانيا في ايطاليا في فرنسا في
بريطانيه بنيامين نتنياهو غير شخصيه غير
محبوبه ولكن بدون شاب الشعوب
العربي في العالم ينظرون الى الوضع في
الاسرائيل يرون
استخلاص
غير
ولكن اذا تلخيص
المحلل السياسي الاسرائيلي من تل ابيب اسف
انتهى انتهى وقتنا نريد ان نتعمق اكثر
بالنقاش معنا من الناصره الدكتور سليم
بريك واستاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
المفتوحه في حيفا ومن بيرمنج هام الدكتور
اسكت لوكس استاذ السياسات الدوليه في معهد
كلينتون بجامعه
سابدا معك سيد لوكس وبالحديث هنا عن
الضغوط الدوليه ما حصل اليوم مع نتنياهو
في في لندن الاحتجاج الذي قدمته
الخارجيه الامريكيه لسفيره تل ابيب في
واشنطن ما الذي يقود السياسه الامريكيه
والسياسه الغربيه عموما تجاه حكومه
نتنياهو اليوم
بدايه انا متاكد ان الاستاذ بريك ربما
سيتحدث عن البعد الداخلي لكن ضيفك السابق
اعتقد انه كان يحاول ان يقلل اهميه ما
يحصل داخل اسرائيل الان ان حزبا لكوت حزب
نتنياهون لا يتمتع باغلبيه المطلقه في
الكنيست هو فقط يمتلكه اكثر من 25 مقعدا
وايضا هو لديه 64 ايضا في
الكنيسه وثلاثه من هؤلاء الاعضاء ربما هم
متارجحين في دعم لذلك فكره ان هذه حكومه
مسيطره بالكامل بالاخذ بنظر الى الاعتبار
ان هذه ازمه حقيقيه تواجهها الديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه اعتقد علي انني يجب ان اطرح
الاسئله حول هذا الامر الدوليا قاده
العالميه رونا ما يحصل ويعرف ان العلاقه
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه نحن
القاده الغرب لا يمكنهم ان حول محاولات
نتنياهو وحكومه الائتلافيه في ان يحاول
السيطره على القضاء لا يمكنهم ان يظلوا
صامتين عن محاولتهم من اجل كسر توازن
القوى بالتالي كان هنالك استدعاء لسفير
الاسرائيلي في واشنطن واخبرونه تنياهو
انهم لا يتوقعوا زياره يتوقع ان يزور
الولايات المتحده نتنياهو تمكننا من زياره
العواصم الاوروبيه كان في المانيا الاسبوع
الماضي وهو الان في لندن في الوقت الذي
نتحدث فيه الان لكن من المهم جدا تذكر ان
المستشار الالماني شولز كان هنالك خلال
مؤتمرا صحفي عبر عن قلق الجانب الالماني
وايضا المملكه المتحده حكومه المملكه
المتحده لما تعطي
فرصه للادلائي او القيامه بمؤتمر صحفي
بالتالي
[موسيقى]
يعني هذا هذا يعيدنا يعيدنا الى طرح اسئله
متعدده حول
يعني اذا كان الغرب او الولايات المتحده
لا ترضى بسياسات نتنياهو فاذا لم تبقى
صامته ما الذي ستفعله هذه اسئله سنحاول
الاجابه عليها لكن اسمح لي انتقل الى
السيد بريك من الناصره الى اي مدى برايك
سيد سليم يمكن لي نتنياهو ان يتجاهل كل
هذه الضغوط هل هو مرتاح على وضعه في
الكنيست ام ماذا
مساء الخير لا باعتقادي نتنياهو غير مرتاح
نحن شفنا بالامس
حديثنا نتنياهو ويمسك الاوراق ويديه ترتجف
وحركه جسمه
يعني غير طبيعيه وغير معتاده وهذا نتنياهو
الذي ياخذ في الحسبان كل شيء بسيط حتى في
وسائل الاعلام وفي التلفزيون باعتقادي انه
الضغط على نتنياهو
ياتي من عده جهات ولعده اسباب اولا الضغط
الداخلي بسبب محاوله نتنياهو الانقلاب
ونحن نقترب من ساعه الصفر في الاسبوع
القادم ربما سيمر قانون الاساس الذي عمليا
يخول الحكومه بانتخاب القضاه وبهذا تنتهي
الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل
القضيه الثانيه هي طبعا انه اسرائيل ترى
نفسها قسم من العالم الديمقراطي والان
العالم الديمقراطي يصفى ان نتنياهو مره
اخرى هو كان في المانيا فتلقى درس من
المانيا ما هي الديمقراطيه
بفرنسا وكان واضح بانه غير مرغوب به في
فرنسا المحك قال الوحيد الذي كان مرغوب به
فيه هو ايطاليا لان هناك حزب فاشي موجود
في الحكم في الولايات المتحده نتنياهو
واضح بانه معادي للحزب الديمقراطي ويستند
على حركه شعبويه مثله مثل ترامب تماما
ولذلك باعتقاده انه غير مرغوب به ايضا في
الولايات المتحده ونحن راينا هذا اليوم في
بريطانيا يعني الصفعه كانت واضحه لنتنياهو
زيارتنا نتنياهو
لندن لم تكن واضحه اللقاء كان اقل من ساعه
كل هذه الامور تدل بان الغرب بدا يفهم بان
هناك محاوله انقلاب على نظام الحكم هناك
حاكم فاسد كل ما يعني هو
تفسيره
المحاكمه سيد سليم ما تفسيره لما نقلته
صحيفه عن مسؤول سياسي كبير في اسرائيل
يقول بان العلاقه مع واشنطن لن تتدهور ولن
يكون هناك تصعيد شامل يعني انت تتحدث الان
وكان هناك نوع او يعني قرب من من الطلاق
بين نتنياهو والغرب او الولايات المتحده
الان الحديث عن ان هذه العلاقه مستمره ولن
تشوبها شائبه
لا لا يجب ان نفصل بين امرين ان نفصل بين
علاقه اسرائيل كدوله مع الولايات المتحده
وهذه العلاقه مستمره وقويه جدا هذه
العلاقه ومع الغرب هي تستند على مصالح
استراتيجيه ضد ايران و ضد تهديدات اخرى
تراها الدول الغربيه الان اسرائيل ايضا
منخرطه في قضيه اوكرانيا مثلا وهناك
مطالبه بان تقوم اسرائيل بمساعده اوكرانيا
وقضيه الغاز لاوروبا كل هذه الامور واضحه
ولكن الحكومه الحاليه هي حكومه غير مرغوب
بها وخصوصا نتنياهو بسبب تصرفاته الغالب
ليس ضد الشعب الاسرائيلي الغرب ليس ضد
دوله اسرائيل وانما الغرب ضد حكومه
اسرائيل الحاليه التي تحاول الانقلاب
وستقوم بالانقلاب على الديمقراطيه وعلى
حقوق الاقليات وكل هذه الامور ماذا سيحدث
الغربيه طبعا هنا هنا سيد لوكاس ماذا
سيفعل للغرب لمنع نتنياهو وحكومته من
الانقلاب بين الى ليلين على الديمقراطيه
كما يراها الغرب في اسرائيل
وانت قلت قبل قليل لا يمكن للولايات
المتحده ولا للدول الغربيه ان تبقى صامته
ما الذي ستفعله
اعتقد بدايه علينا ان نوضح انه ليس هنالك
اي قوه فان سواء كانت الولايات المتحده او
الاتحاد الاوروبي او اي قوه اخرى بامكانها
ان تتدخل لايقاف نتنياهو من محاولته في ان
كما وصفه الاستاذ بريك في الانقلاب على
الديمقراطيه الامر يعود للشعب الاسرائيلي
والمؤسسات الاسرائيليه لكي تقف وتواجه
نتنياهو كما راينا مثلا من المدعي العام
اليوم قالت ان نتنياهو وافعالها هي ليس
ليست مقبوله وليست قانونيه لكن ما تحا-
تستطيع الولايات المتحده والدول الاخرى
القياديه الا تعطيه ملاذا امنا لا يمكنها
ان تعامله على انه رئيس دوله يتمتع بشارع
ويقوم باخذ القرارات لمصلحه الشعب
الاسرائيلي الاستاذ بريك محق لنر
العلاقات او تاثير في العلاقات بين
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده من الناحيه
العسكريه والاقتصاديه ونعرف القضايا
المهمه القضايا الفلسطينيه القضايا
الاقليميه وقضيه ايران ايضا لكن فيما
يتعلق بما يحدث في السياسات الداخليه
الاسرائيليه فان الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي والمجتمع الدولي برماته
ان يوضحه انه لا يمكنه ان يعتمد علينا من
اجل ان يحصل على الدعم اذا ما كان هنالك
انتفاضه من اجل مقاومته في محاوله السيطره
على القضاء سلسليم بريك ما بين الدعم
الخارجي والدعم الداخلي ماذا سيفضل
نتنياهو يعني ان يحظى بدعم خارجي او ان
يحظى بدعم الاحزاب اليمينيه
المتطرفه كما هو الحال حاليا ايهما افضل
بالنسبه اليه
باعتقادي هو موجود في ازمه حقيقيه وهو
يعاني من هذه الازمه بشكل حقيقي باعتقاده
كل السفراته بنهايه الاسبوع لدول مختلفه
هي هروب من دوله اسرائيل
نتنياهو في نهايه المطاف يريد ان يخلص
نفسه من السجن ومن العقاب على كل ما هو
متهم فيه ولذلك هو مستمر بهذه الطريقه
اولا ثانيا الشركاء الطبيعيين لنتنياهوهم
الحركات حركه الدينيه الصهيونيه المتطرفه
والعنصريه التي عمليا تعيد الاستيطان في
الضفه الغربيه وتعتدي على المواطنين
الفلسطينيين هناك والحريدين الذين يريدون
دوله دينيه هنا انا اعتقد بان نتنياهو
مشكله مع يهود العالم مع يهود الولايات
المتحده ويهود اوروبا لان
الحركات الاصوليه الدينيه في اسرائيل التي
هي شريكه في الحكومه لا ترى بقسم كبير
منها يهود العالم يهود حقيقيين ولذلك
لنتنياهو مشكله ايضا في الولايات المتحده
وفي اوروبا الغربيه لا شك فيها
طيب يعني عندما تتحدث عن هذا الانطعاض
الامريكي او الامتعاض الغربي وتوحي وكانه
هناك مطالب على نتنياهو ان
يحققها او على الاقل على ان يتراجع عن تلك
القرارات والاصلاحات القضائيه التي يعتزم
المضي بها طيب
الغرب الا يعرف بان هذه القرارات
التي يقوم بها ارضاء لليمين هي التي تبقيه
في كرسي رئاسه الحكومه يعني وكان الغرب
يطلب منا نتنياهو التخلي عن رئاسه الحكومه
والخروج من الحكم
مره اخرى انا لا اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده او المملكه المتحده والتي عملت
بنيامين نتنياهو على انه
الرئيس وزراء اسرائيل اليوم انه سيطلبون
منه ان يتخلوا عن الحكم سيقولون ان الامر
يعود للشعب الاسرائيلي والنظام الاسرائيلي
لكن علينا ان نعود الى الاسس الاساس لحصول
هذه الازمه بسبب ان بنيامين كان يواجهه
محاكمه في الوقت الذي كان يتم اعاده
انتخابك رئيس وزراء كان يواجه محاكمه
بتهمي ريشه وكان قد تمكن من انقاذ نفسه
وتفادي
السجن وبالتالي هاجم النظام القضائي وهذا
الامر يختلف عن مساله الاستيطان وعن
التعامل مع القضيه الفلسطينيه بشكل كامل
والامر يختلف ايضا عن التعامل مع الملف
الايراني هو الرساله واضحه من الغرب نحن
قلقون من ايران كحالك انت ونحن قلقون من
ما في المنطقه لكن لك يمكنك ان تستخدمه
تلك القضايا للتستر
ولمحاوله مهاجمه النظام الديمقراطي نحن لا
نتحدث عن العراق او سوريا خلال السنوات
الاخيره لنرى اي قوى تجبر نتنياهو على
التخلي عن القوى ولكننا لن نرى لكننا نرى
دعما للمظاهرات السلميه والاحتجاجات
السلميه في اسرائيل
كما ترى في سفرته الخارجيه المتعدده هل
يمكن ان يهرب بعمل ما ضد الفلسطينيين ان
يهرب من ازمته الداخليه الى الامام
بشيء ما ضد الجانب الفلسطيني
انا لا اعتقد باعتقادي انه نتنياهو يعود
للقسم بالحكومه الذي يريد تهدئه الامور في
في الضفه الغربيه وليس العكس وهذا لا يخدم
نتنياهو في نهايه المطاف الان اولا هناك
يعني طول الوقت تهديدات كمان من الضفه
الغربيه كمان من قطاع غزه وكمان من لبنان
حتى الان في اسرائيل في قلق شديد مما حدث
في
العمليه الاخيره التي كانت في ميغيدو
وهناك الكثير من الاسرار لم تتضح حتى الان
باعتقادنا نتنياهو لا يفتش عن هذا الموضوع
نتناول مصر على ان ينتخب هو الحكام الذين
يحاكموه وان يفرض هذا على على المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وما فاجاه بان المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بما في ذلك الجيش يعني لاحظ ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كثيرين من الضباط واليوم
نسمع كل يوم عن مئات يقولون نحن الجنود في
جيش دوله اسرائيل كان جيش الشعب وليس جيش
حاكم مستبد مثل بنيامين نتنياهو يعني في
شرخ عميق في الجيش الاسرائيلي ولا يمكن
لاحد ان يتغاضى عن هذا الموضوع في نهايه
المطاف باعتقادي انه نتنياهو يدعن للضغوط
الاقتصاديه والامنيه ويجب ان يجد حل لهذا
الموضوع شكرا للدكتور سليم بريك من
الناصره وشكرا للدكتور اسكت لوكاس كان
معنا من
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]